around the tip of a tardigrid's mouth
are small bumps that we think act like
little sensors and when those bumps make
contact with a rotifer out pops the
tardigrades style it a little needle
that pokes out from the tubular mouth
opening that style it pokes into the
rotifer and from there the tardigrade
uses a circular structure called a
pharynx in its head to create strong
suction and then the stylet goes from
functioning as a needle to functioning
as a portable built-in straw that lets
the tardigrade suck out the inside of
its prey
you can see some of that bodily fluid
leaving the rotifer as the tardigrade
style it pumps away like a beating heart
and when she is done the rotifer remains
like an empty coffee cup